largas colas durante todo el día en
chile frente a las oficinas de pensiones
este lunes comenzaba el proceso para que
hasta 10 millones de chilenos pudieran
retirar el 10% del dinero de sus cuentas
se trata del tercer retiro desde junio
del año pasado
justificado por la crisis que atraviesan
los ciudadanos debido a la pandemia sólo
de atención a hoy los rótulos de la
plata de un alcanza con lo que zarco de
pensiones
y con esa plata aceptará chen de joe no
me alcanza
por eso retiro el 10% tapó el bid y le
sobrevino vivir este tercer retiro se
realiza con la aprobación del parlamento
pero sin el beneplácito del gobierno de
sebastián piñera que vio como la corte
constitucional rechazó el recurso de
inconstitucionalidad que interpuso para
frenar la medida sin embargo genera
también controversia entre la población
muchas personas están a tos llegadas por
las deudas pero temen quedarse sin
pensiones en el futuro
no en vano en torno a tres millones de
personas ya se quedaron sin fondos
suficientes en febrero para este tercer
retiro y que cómo está la situación
hay que saber sacarlo
te digo igual yo creo que el estado
debería de actuar la pensión de gracia a
los que no tienen nada yo tengo un
barrio años más para trabajar y me
puedes poner pero para la gente que no
tiene tiene que saber sacando la
discusión se enroca también en torno al
modelo de pensiones creado en 1981 bajo
la dictadura de pinochet y que obliga a
todos los trabajadores a destinar el 10%
de su salario a un fondo de pensiones
privado la principal queja de los
chilenos es el poco beneficio que
obtienen especialmente si se compara con
las ganancias que obtienen las seis
administradoras de pensiones oficiales